crap
crap
crappuccino
charlie craplin in colombia when the old
man starts yelling at the mail we put
them on a sandbar and wait for the tie
to come in well delgado's got a doozy of
a valentine's dilemma i texted out
feelers for two dates vicky noah's top
choice but alexa potts has been doing
this bad girl thing lately i'm into so
while i wait for a yes from noah i've
got to keep pots in the back burner oh
my god is it still talking jay that's so
rude he overthinks everything if you
have a shot at the bad girl jump i don't
know she has a stepdad who only pays
attention to her hot older sister i will
dial the phone for you ah
that was joe's school he's in trouble we
need to go meet with the teacher what
the hell did he do he robbed a bank and
took 18 hostages how would i know let's
go
it's a no-go alexa wanted to use the hot
tub tonight but apparently can't find
her bathing suit if you don't come home
smelling of light beer and chlorine do
not come home at all
i asked you guys to come in today
because joe has given me a very um
inappropriate valentine's day gift
i assume that
he got this from home miss clark i am so
sorry i'm sure that joe doesn't even
know what he was doing oh
looks like i'm finally gonna get to
fight with one son over the sports
illustrated swimsuit issue jake this is
not funny
i come from a very long line of overly
sexy men my cousin ricardo he had a sex
addiction you mean addiction
yes sorry he built an addiction onto his
house for making love to his many
girlfriends well joe just needs to know
that this type of gift is not okay and
you're right i'm gonna talk to him
did i do something wrong you did take
something out of your mom's drawer
without asking but i'm gonna give you a
pass on that one
the thing is the gift was inappropriate
well you give underpass to mom it's true
you do it every year
look
you can give that kind of thing to your
wife or your girlfriend
but it's a little bit different when
it's your teacher okay fine could i go
back to the quiet room now i already
missed tops on my nap you know how i get
sure go ahead
everything's squared away miss clark
sorry for the trouble math the back oh
my gosh i'm sorry
i didn't know that real humans could
have these dimensions
thank you
mom i'm home
we got valentine's day oh
hi miss keeley is the party over we had
an incident your son gave my bailey a
very strange valentine's gift
i am so sorry
didn't your father talk to you about
this already yeah he said it's okay to
give it to a girlfriend we're going and
bailey is certainly not his girlfriend
she will be lucky
is that bailey cause i think joe has a
little thing for her yeah he did had a
little thing for her it's here he did it
again
i knew i shouldn't have trust you
talking to him because you will let him
get away with murder because he's a mini
you and you like it and you know what's
worse that you're so mean to manny
because he's different than you first
off joe is not a mini me crap
crapola kravinsky oh maybe a little
and maybe i kind of like it but why
would you want to knock the j out of joe
instead of one trophy you get two
what'd i miss
this overpaid bum mr putt
the first time i'm supposed to not like
this
well call me an idiot jay sure enough
alexa and i did end up in a hot tub
together but around her third beer i
suggested she have some water to stay
hydrated she tried to shut me up by
kissing me which i liked but she kept
calling me travis
oh my god is it still talking
joe
you don't ever disrespect your brother
like that and no more giving underwear
to little girls or anyone else cause
it's creepy and european now go to your
room
it's fun when your kids get your best
qualities but it's a kick in the gut
when they pick up stuff you hate about
yourself
i saw that ugly impatient part of me
coming out of my adorable son
in fairness that adorable part also came
from me
we both got my mom's crabapple cheeks
and pillow lips
[Music]
you